[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición el tema central será el
cannabidiol conocido como se ve de una
molécula del cannabis que no tiene
efectos psicotrópicos en el último año
ese ha sido un negocio que ha prosperado
mucho aquí en francia aunque bajo
estricta reglamentación y a pesar de que
hay ciertas variedades que se permiten
cultivar y vender aquí en la francia el
gobierno quiere una reglamentación mucho
más restrictiva luego hablaremos con el
profesor amin benjamin a él es el
presidente de la federación francesa
para el tratamiento de adicciones él nos
explicará cuáles son los beneficios de
consumir estos productos para la salud y
luego les traeremos los perfiles de dos
candidatos de la izquierda francesa a
las elecciones presidenciales que
tendrán lugar el próximo mes de abril
por una parte es un look meloso un
experimentado en política y por otro y
aniquilado de europa ecología los verdes
en su segundo intento por llegar a la
presidencia
en el último año en las calles de parís
y de las principales ciudades francesas
han proliferado boutiques que venden
productos acb de esta molécula del
cannabis que no es estupefaciente sin
embargo el futuro de este negocio es
incierto actualmente los representantes
del sector y el gobierno se enfrentan en
un mano a mano jurídico el gobierno
quiere prohibir la venta de flores y de
hojas de cannabis a través de un decreto
ministerial que fue emitido a finales
del año pasado sin embargo a comienzos
de 2022 las altas cortes francesas
revocaron esta medida temporalmente
rafael freund junto con 12 socios
abrieron esta boutique hace un año todos
son apasionados por el cannabis y sus
variadas propiedades
el cb es un cannabinoide entre más de
160 la diferencia principal es que el cb
de heno es un psicotrópico comparado al
thc que si ese estupefaciente
con unos estos emprendedores no olvidan
que por ley los productos que ofrecen no
pueden contener más de 0.3 por ciento de
thc eso es está viva va a regular el
sueño ayuda a regular el apetito el
estrés la ansiedad algunos dolores
tenemos clientes que nos han dicho que
el cb funciona mejor que la morfina
la gama de productos con cbd es variada
champú jabones cremas para la cara
chocolates y aguas aromáticas los
precios oscilan entre los 5 y 115 euros
los clientes son en promedio mayores de
30 años una clientela que ya tiene
algunos productos favoritos
muchos aceites sublinguales son fáciles
de consumir en unas pocas gotas bajo la
lengua y los cosméticos llaman mucho la
atención
también la flor que es para la gente que
tomates o quienes solían fumar y ahora
la vaporizar
en francia hay cerca de 2.000 boutiques
de este tipo el doble de hace un año un
sector que se desarrolló apoyándose en
un fallo de la corte de justicia de la
unión europea de noviembre de 2020 el
comercio de productos de cvd estuvo
prohibido desde 1990 en francia a
finales de 2021 el gobierno emitió un
decreto en el que prohibía de nuevo la
venta de flores y hojas de cannabis cb
de guadalix combi que representa a la
asociación francesa de productores de
cannabinoides y explica cuáles fueron
sus argumentos ante el consejo de estado
para pedir se revierta el decreto
gubernamental
para nosotros los artículos del código
de salud pública que dan un marco a esta
cuestión y definen las nociones del
psicotrópico y de sustancias venenosas
pero no de manera suficientemente
precisa y como esto también enmarca una
libertad que es la libertad de industria
y comercio se necesita que fueran más
precisos y explicar que es un
estupefaciente en enero de este año
cortes galas suspendieron temporalmente
esta medida gubernamental aclarando que
el cb de no es ni estupefaciente ni
nocivo para la salud a la espera de un
fallo final rafael no está preocupado
por el futuro de su negocio ni de esta
actividad que genera cerca de 25 mil
empleos y deja ganancias anuales por
unos 1000 millones de euros de hecho en
pocos días abrirá en esta tienda un
salón de té
estamos en el hospital paul bocuse aquí
en parís y nos acompaña el profesor amin
benyamina el es el presidente de la
federación francesa para el tratamiento
de adicciones profesor gracias por
acompañarnos gracias por invitarme en
francia la ley prohíbe que estas
boutiques que venden estos productos con
cannabidiol hagan una promoción de los
efectos terapéuticos que pueden tener
estos productos sin embargo la gente
cuando va a estas estas boutiques
también va buscando productos que les
puedan ayudar con tratamientos de
ciertos dolores algunos incluso de
origen oncológico
también para problemas de sueño qué tan
cierto son estos efectos benéficos
vivimos en una gran hipocresía de ambos
lados primero las boutiques cuando
abrieron el fin no es sólo vender
bienestar sino también el de promover
claramente el cannabis en su forma
terapéutica
entonces los gerentes de estas boutiques
han utilizado hasta el límite de sus
posibilidades es decir la presencia en
un 0,2 por ciento de thc en los que
contienen una mayoría de cannabis de
óleo y un falso
y del otro lado tenemos un gobierno y
una ley que no es totalmente clara sobre
el asunto y que está siendo desafiada
con la llegada de esas boticas
es cierto que en teoría y oficialmente
son productos de confort productos de
cosmética pero detrás lo que se piensa
es ofrecer productos terapéuticos cupos
de política y así pues como puede tener
estos digamos beneficios también tiene
efectos contraproducentes
es un cannabinoide muy interesante por
razones asociadas al producto que se
consume de forma clandestina
es decir el cannabis que se consume en
las calles ahora nos dimos cuenta que la
composición de los productos que
consumen personas con cuestiones de
ebriedad en una fiesta podrían más o
menos tener una concentración de
cannabis versus el thc es decir el
producto psicoactivo del
tetrahidrocannabinol luego nos dimos
cuenta de que en los productos en los
que había un equilibrio una proporción
entre el cannabis
y ese producto era menos nocivo para la
salud en especial para la salud psíquica
de 12 a 11
entonces pronto nos interesamos en el
cannabis doble por conocer sus virtudes
que se utilizan para uso terapéutico por
ejemplo sus virtudes para dormir la
relajación la ansiedad el dolor y es
claro que el cannabidiol tiene muy pocos
efectos secundarios y efectos nocivos
porque por cada billón hablando más
acerca de digamos el tema de adicciones
hay algunos de los consumidores que van
a estos lugares a comprar hojas y flores
de cannabidiol para tomarlos en aguas
aromáticas pero también para vaporizar
los inhalar los algunos incluso hasta lo
fuman y algunos incluso insisten en que
esto les ha ayudado a dejar su adicción
al cannabis thc y
siempre hay un riesgo para quienes
llamamos consumidor ingenuo de probar el
cannabis en el que hay thc que comience
a apreciar los efectos del thc y a
aumentar la concentración en thc el
riesgo no es inexistente de ahí que sea
muy importante no bajar la guardia por
eso se necesita una ley porque esto
tiene efectos en dos poblaciones
vulnerables los jóvenes que ahora pueden
experimentar el cannabis comprando en
una boutique y que en realidad lo que
están buscando es la parte del thc y las
personas que tienen problemas
psiquiátricos y que para luchar contra
su angustia o para manejar un
sufrimiento mental o problemas de sueño
prueban el thc pero lo que puedo
decirles es que el riesgo es mucho menos
importante para el consumidor de este
tipo de productos que para quienes lo
compran en el mercado ilegal y de los
cuales no tenemos información alguna en
europa los que más consumen cannabis son
los franceses y al mismo tiempo de una
serie de campañas de prevención en
especial para las personas entre los 18
y los 34 años que son quienes más
consumen este estupefaciente pero con la
llegada de la decana vídeo el esto no
podría interferir en el mensaje que se
quiere transmitir en materia de adicción
de problemática en el tratamiento de
adicciones sin importar el producto lo
más importante es decir las cosas
claramente y señalar los sea cual sea el
producto así sea lícito el tabaco el
cannabis hay que trabajar en la
prevención con un discurso muy claro e
identificar las poblaciones que no deben
consumir y que deben ser protegidas no
es antinómico ni contradictorio promover
el cannabis con cannabis doll y prohibir
el cannabis con thc elevado a las
poblaciones vulnerables la prevención no
es tarea del comerciante sino del estado
que es el garante de la salud de todos y
que también es el garante del comercio y
del comercio internacional así como de
la coherencia de las políticas
internacionales por ahora francia va muy
tarde en esto de hecho vendemos
medicamentos a base de opiáceos a pesar
de que la heroína está prohibida
vendemos paracetamol con codeína que es
un excelente analgésico aún cuando la
heroína está prohibida va a hacer lo
mismo con el cannabis se va a promover
el cannabis con cannabis para todo lo
que está indicado que sabemos es una
ventaja contra dolores como los de la
esclerosis múltiple pero se prohibirá el
cannabis con los altos niveles de thc
para los jóvenes porque sabemos que
entre más se consume a temprana y más se
corre el riesgo de ser dependiente y más
riesgo hay de tener problemas
psicológicos sociales y escolares pues
habrá que continuar entonces ese debate
gracias profesor media mina para estar
con nosotros aquí en france 24
como les anunciamos al comienzo de
nuestro programa a partir de esta
edición les estaremos trayendo los
perfiles de los principales candidatos a
la elección presidencial en francia esta
tendrá lugar el próximo mes de abril
comenzamos con ian y grado candidato de
europa ecología los verdes
manejados por segunda vez y a sus 54
años aspira a la presidencia de francia
repite su candidatura cinco años después
como representante del partido
europa-ecología a los verdes economista
de profesión desde final de la década de
los 90 ha formado parte de varias ong de
ecología hasta llegar a manejar las
compañías de greenpeace francia a
comienzos de los 2000 lo que vemos son
barcos muy potentes que pescan un gran
número de atún es que sobre explotan el
ecosistema
hay que retomar prácticas de pesca que
no sólo sean buenas para los pescadores
sino que protejan el ecosistema para que
mañana todavía podamos en su juventud
fue militante del partido socialista y
en 1999 decidió sumarse a los verdes
hasta el 2008 cuando se unieron a europa
ecología un año después fue elegido
diputado europeo cargo que ocupa desde
entonces hasta la actualidad su
candidatura presidencial anterior en
2017 la abandonó para apoyar a benoit
hamon aspirante del partido socialista
llega a la carrera electoral de 2022
después de ganar las primarias de su
partido en septiembre del año pasado su
programa de gobierno se centra en la
lucha contra la inacción climática y las
desigualdades
línea
no hay ninguna candidatura ni un
proyecto que respete el acuerdo de parís
sobre el clima que respete la protección
de la vida y que genere compromisos en
torno a los llamados extraordinarios de
justicia social y revitalización de
nuestra democracia
en los últimos cinco años los verdes han
ganado terreno en francia aprovechando
los desilusionados por las promesas
incumplidas del gobierno actual en
cuanto a medio ambiente y el partido
socialista casi extinto en las pasadas
elecciones municipales
2020 la ola verde ganó las alcaldías de
ciudades como burdeos marsella y
estraburgo por ahora en las encuestas
yannick jadot cuenta con el 5.7 por
ciento de intención de voto son lic
melón son se considera el líder de la
oposición de izquierda al gobierno de
manuel bajó en abril intentará llegar al
elíseo por el partido la francis güiza
por un perdón le puede parecer algo
curioso pero nunca antes me había
sentido tan listo para gobernar como me
siento ahora
determinado así se presentaron vínculos
o a las elecciones presidenciales de
francia a sus 71 años este filósofo y
político de izquierda nacido en
marruecos cree que la tercera será la
vencida a mediados de los años 70 inició
su carrera en las filas del partido
socialista pero en 2005 la brecha
ideológica entre él y ese partido se
consolidó por el apoyo que melón song
dio a la campaña por el no en el
referendo sobre una constitución europea
en 2008 melón fundó el partido de
izquierda logrando además un escaño en
el parlamento europeo para la elección
presidencial de 2012 formó alianza con
el partido comunista francés y logró el
11 por ciento de los votos resultado que
fue considerado un éxito en la historia
de la izquierda dura se le conoce por su
franco hablar y por ser polémico nunca
ha ocultado su admiración por el
chavismo como lo muestra este tuit tras
la victoria de nicolás maduro en 2013 la
venezuela bolivariana es para nosotros
fuente de inspiración saludamos la
victoria de maduro en la primavera de
2016 anunció su candidatura a la
presidencia esta vez fundando un nuevo
partido la francia e insumisa obtuvo el
19.5 por ciento de los votos de nuevo un
récord pero no para pasar a la segunda
vuelta para 2022 melón quien ejerce como
parlamentario se la vuelve a jugar el
porvenir en común es el lema de su
programa entre sus propuestas una
asamblea constituyente que lleve a
fundar la sexta república por ahora el
jefe de los insumisos sólo cuenta con el
10% de intención de voto
hasta aquí esta edición de francia en
foco gracias por habernos acompañado
continúen con nuestra programación en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom